Bonjour, c'est Cyprien
Il fait beau, il fait chaud
Vous allez passer un été inoubliable
qui va être complètement ruiné à cause de... Stop!
Ces put*BIP* d'encul*BIP* de moustiques de mer*BIP* !!
ça te pourrit tout les étés de ta vie,
ce conn*BIP* de moustique, va te casser les couil*BIP*, matins, midis et soirs !
Pourquoi il peut pas faire comme ...Heu.. Comme la mouche ? Hein ?
Voler et se faire écraser, c'est très bien ça !
Mais, non il faut qu'il te pique alors ça te gratte, alors tu grattes, alors ça te fait une croûte donc tu regrattes.
Ça te dure comme ça 1 an dans ta vie !
Alors tu deviens paranoïaque ...
Tu développes la technique de la carapace.
C'est-à-dire que tu te crées une armure avec ta couverture pendant la nuit,
pour empêcher le moustique d'entrer en contact avec toi.
C'est plutôt efficace.
Sauf quand ce fils*BIP* de put*BIP* de moustique est déjà dans la carapace.
*Hurlements*
Tu deviens tellement parano que tu élabores des stratagèmes.
Bon déjà il fait trop chaud donc tu es obligé d'ouvrir les fenêtres.
Par contre, tu n'allumes pas la lumière... Ah ça non ! Ca non. Ca serait attirer ce f*BIP* de put*BIP* de moustique vers toi !
NON ! Donc tu passes tout l'été dans le noir comme un blaireau.
Génial !
Bon ! C'est bon là?? On allume la lumière ! Non!! Surtout pas , ça ferait venir les moustiques.
Mais ?! On est en train de manger là, quand même !
Tais toi ! Je suis sûr qu'ils nous entendent en plus !
Ces put*BIP* de moustiques te rendent tellement psychopathe que tu vas même jusqu'à créer un leurre, hein !
Tu vas allumer la lumière plus loin, pour faire partir le moustique. Ne faites pas semblant ... On l'a tous fait ! Tous...
Ça modifie même notre manière de vivre ! Hein ! On veut absolument écraser ce trou du cu*BIP* de moustique.
Alors dans le doute on tape ! Ce qui fait qu'on adopte un comportement qui fait plutôt peur aux enfants.
Eh ! Salut ! ... Ça va ?... Ouais ! Bah moi, je suis tombé en dépression ... Ouais ... Insomnie ... Et ... Beaucoup d'alcool ...
Le pire dans cette histoire, c'est que ... Bon ... Imaginons, t'as réussi à écraser ce moustique ...
Ouaissss !!! T'es plutôt content ... Ouaissss !!
Et là ce que t'as oublié, c'est qu'il n'y a que la femelle qui pique ! Donc à tout moment tu as écrasé un moustique,
qui de toute façon ne t'aurait rien fait et pendant ce temps là, la femelle en a profité pour te niquer. Héééé !!!
Merde !!!
Et une fois que tu as utilisé le bâton incandescent à la citronnelle, la crème à la citronnelle, le patch, la prise,
la technique de la carapace, le stratagème de la lumière, tu te tournes vers des choses un p'tit peu plus mystiques
Comme par exemple les logiciels ou les applications pour téléphone qui envoient des ultrasons pour éloigner le moustique.
Voilà ! Cette application aurait pu s'appeler:
Ça ne marche pas !
Je sais que dans le désespoir, on peut croire que ... Mais non ! Ca ne marche pas hein !
Vous vous faites piquer et on vous prend pour des cons !
Je crois que le truc qui me fait le plus haïr les moustiques, de tout ton corps, en entier,
pourquoi, le moustique te pique à cet endroit ?
Heu, bonjour. Voilà, je viens d'arriver ce matin dans l’entreprise,
j'espère que ça va bien se passer entre nous.
Hein, vous êtes déjà très souriants, à ce que je vois.
On m'a même déjà donné un surnom, on m'appelle "le bouton", à l'accueil.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi...
Bor*BIP de mer*BIP ... Si toi aussi tu détestes les moustiques, partage cette vidéo sur facebook et rejoins ma page ...
Face à eux, ensemble, on sera plus forts !
Et un soir d'insomnie, dans ta carapace, tu peux aller sur cyprien.fr pour voir toutes mes autres vidéos. Voilà.
Je pense à vous tout simplement!